ils sont allés au bout de les forces
samedi 14 janvier 96 pistards dont 16
féminines ont participé à ses 6 heures
du Vélodrome national la compétition
était programmée pour la troisième fois
sur la piste 5 continents c'est une
épreuve d'endurance par équipe de trois
ou quatre coureurs qui se relaient qui
se relève environ toutes les demi-heures
et le but du jeu c'est de faire le plus
grand nombre de tours possible dans
pendant 6 heures cinq catégories étaient
présentes sur la piste les coureurs
venus principalement de la région
francilienne ont du s'employé pour être
le mieux classé sur cette compétition
amicale
il avait déjà fait il y a trois quatre
ans en équipe 100% féminine et on
l'avait gagné je trouve ça sympa parce
que ça réunit toutes les catégories les
filles les gars et puis on vient on
prend du plaisir et ouais c'est plutôt
chouette je suis surprise à la première
fois que je le fais et c'est hyper dur
on essaie de mettre en place des
stratégies qui sont idéales pour que bah
pour jouer la gaine quoi on aura fait 6
heures ça va se jouer à deux tours près
quoi donc ça va être c'est tendu ce
rendez-vous devrait revenir l'année
prochaine au même date elle devrait donc
une nouvelle fois être la première
compétition de l'année au vélo vélo
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines